[Musique]
n'dongo bienvenue à toutes et à tous
nous sommes dans un endroit exceptionnel
le cercle interallié de paris l'ancienne
résidence des arts et l'ambassade russe
au 19e siècle
c'est ici cet hôtel particulier de
faubourg saint-honoré à deux pas des
champs-elysées que les plus beaucoup
plus de la capitale se sont donné rendez
vous pour célébrer le nouvel an russe
pour cette première émission de l'année
je vous ai préparé un programme sur
mesure de la danse avec un grand
chorégraphe russe boris eifman que j'ai
rencontré à saint pétersbourg
et bel opéra avec prince igor de l'opéra
bastille littéralement transporté le
public en décembre dernier à paris
[Musique]
vous êtes prêts pour un voyage plein de
grâce et de musique je vous amène de
lisbonne à vladivostok
[Musique]
je vous présente boris eifman l'un des
plus grands chorégraphes contemporains
russes
il a fondé sa compagnie en 1977
et depuis ces balles et font le tour du
monde paris accueille aujourd'hui ces
deux spectacles
deux créations anna karénine et rodin
deux balles et qui ont pour point commun
de traiter d'un thème universel l'amour
et les souffrances qui peuvent en
découler d'un côté la relation
tumultueuse entre le maître de la
sculpture et son élève et de l'autre le
triangle amoureux
imaginé par tolstoï
[Musique]
dans ses créations eichmann pousse sans
arrêt l'innovation il ne se cantonne pas
aux principes classiques de la danse et
cherche toujours à être un accord avec
son époque
[Musique]
une des caractéristiques du ballet c'est
qu'il a tendance à vieillir très vite
c'est pourquoi tous les chorégraphes du
monde essaie de faire en sorte que leurs
balais soit les prix moderne possible en
utilisant différentes technologies
modernes et en mélangeant les spectacles
avec d'autres arts visuels ou
dramatiques pour moi c'est très
important car avant le ballet russe
était présentée plus tôt de manière
traditionnelle classique est ancien il
est plus considéré comme un ballet
contemporain
maintenant on comprend que le style
avant-garde n'est pas seulement quelque
chose de vendeurs mais il aide à montrer
le ballet autrement hiroshi tamaki
mélange de danse classique et
contemporaine le ballet est présenté
aujourd'hui au palais des congrès anna
karénine transpire l'exigence de son
créateur
maria abakumova interprètent leurs
titres
c'est difficile de travailler avec
eichmann d'ailleurs ce n'est jamais
facile de travailler mais je dirais non
car je suis chanceuse j'aime beaucoup
son travail
notre travail n'est pas simple mais il
finit toujours par payer quand tu vas
sur scène tu reçois tous ces
applaudissements les fleurs tu voi
enthousiasme dans les regards des
spectateurs de 7 en fait ce n'est pas
seulement taper en fin de mois
mais cette récompense du travail que tu
as fourni que tu attends ici sur scène
tu reçois beaucoup plus et je reçois
cela chaque représentation
anna karénine c'est un monument de la
culture russe connu dans le monde entier
l'oeuvre de tolstoï a été adapté maintes
et maintes fois
celle de f m'hamdi faire plaçant
l'expression des corps au coeur de
l'adaptation pour raconter cette passion
amoureuse dévastatrice oleg et michel
interprète le personnage d'alix yvrande
ski
c'est un drame pour actes balle est que
tout dommage qu'au jeu c'est un drame
authentique qui va être jouée en deux
actes un ballet qui me semblent n'a pas
besoin de publicité il fait sa propre
publicité grâce à tous les lieux où il a
été joué tous les théâtres de capitale
où il s'est produit aux jeunes je tourne
à calais c'est anna karénine et grâce
non seulement aux livres mais aussi à
l'adaptation au cinéma grâce à tous ceux
qui parlent de la culture russe tout le
monde connaît l'oeuvre
il ya aussi le langage de la danse cela
crée des relations interculturelles
d'être les accointances et puis c'est
toujours intéressant de voir comment un
chorégraphe interprète toutes ses
pensées importante de ce grand écrivain
-
[Musique]
c'est bien
c'est mon premier valais oui
plus tôt
le rapport du ballet que j'avais pu voir
quitter
en classique éléments de touche dans ce
conte en
oren
c'était très sympa à découvert est un
mélange oeufs
théâtre muet d'expression corporelle
différentes
des costumes on est ravis on est dans
son
très explicite avec leur corps
magnifique
le mouvement là le rythme la musique
c'était d'époustouflants la musique de
tchaïkovski aussi fin est vraiment à
nous emporter dans cet univers
extraordinaire
de tolstoï retranscrit à merveille je
trouve par aubry cette manne j'ai
vraiment été très très émue j'ai versé
ma petite larme heures je quitte paris
pour prendre maintenant la direction de
saint-pétersbourg hyperactif et fun il
ne s'est pas limité à la création de
vallée il a également ouvert une école
de danse dédié aux jeunes générations de
nombreuses étoiles ont effectué leurs
premiers pas d'un sauna ghanimi à saint
pétersbourg on prend les enfants de
l'âge de six ans et on leur apprend en
même temps la danse classique et la
danse moderne
on leur apprend que l'art de la danse
est très varié doivent comprendre qu'ils
peuvent mélanger les styles et les
traditions
c'est d'ailleurs très important pour un
artiste car il existe chez les artistes
ce complexe de danser que du classique
des votes c'est pourquoi de nous
éduquons une nouvelle génération
d'artistes qui comprendra que le théâtre
d'aujourd'hui est un mélange de
plusieurs arts nous voyons déjà les
résultats de notre système d'éducation
aux élèves sont plus expressifs et
répondent plus aux exigences du ballet
contemporain qui concerne les techniques
elles sont vraiment très différentes
on a engagé beaucoup de spécialistes de
l'europe et d'amérique pour donner des
cours différents
on donne l'envié à nos élèves de créer
eux mêmes leurs chorégraphies
ce soir c'est une nouvelle étape pour f
man après son école et les n'augure son
théâtre
toujours à saint pétersbourg et là
encore dédié aux jeunes danseurs que
j'ai pu rencontrer
[Musique]
pour cet événement plusieurs générations
d'élèves deichtmann participent au
spectacle
en coulisses les jeunes artistes se
prépare déjà
c'est le spectacle oui on est un peu
inquiète
juste un peu oui même le professeur est
inquiète et qu'est ce que vous faites
pour vous détendre
on pense au spectacle on se met en
condition on se met en condition et sa
cuve l'iran de sourire en avignon
d'accord celles qui seraient pas sur la
punit oui on va être surveillé bon jeu
très bien je vous souhaite un très beau
spectacle
merci je ne stresse pas je suis
tranquille
en général le stress arrive au moment où
je dois monter sur scène et après une
fois que tu es sur celles qui oublient
toute inquiétude et tu commence vraiment
à prendre du plaisir parce que pour ce
spectacle de gala
les apprentis se mêlent danseurs
professionnels et parmi eux la danseuse
principale du ballet d'état de berlin
elsa carillon
dia sigma gouasmia passera déjà vérifié
titre c'est aujourd'hui j'ai assisté aux
répétitions et c'est appréciable de voir
à quel point les enfants sont talentueux
et désireux d'aller sur scène
j'adore travailler avec les enfants car
ils perçoivent le travail différemment
ils sont toujours très heureux et très
joyeux ils n'ont jamais peur de se
présenter devant le public et pour moi
c'est très important de les observer
parce que quand tu n'est plus aussi
jeune
je commence à t'inquiéter et a stressé
avant le spectacle quand je regarde ses
enfants avant le spectacle tout de suite
je me trouve une seconde jeunesse
et cela renforce ma motivation pour
venir danser sur scène
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au revoir cher saint pétersbourg je dois
rentrer à paris
j'ai rendez-vous à l'opéra bastille pour
assister à la représentation de prince
igor qui est à l'affiché pendant un mois
au début de l'hiver
[Musique]
je vous invite à découvrir l'unique
opéra écrit par alexandre borodine trois
heures et demie de spectacle l'histoire
d'un roi qui questionne nos valeurs
morales la mise en scène de baricco xi a
abandonné la fac l'heure pour livrer une
lecture moderne de l'oeuvre les épées et
les armures laisse place au tri et au
kalachnikov
un banc d'autoroute un parking bétonné
ou une villa avec piscine on remplaçait
les décors du passé et même les célèbres
danses polovtsiennes s'inspire du
folklore mexicain
je profite de ce moment pour discuter un
peu avec ildar abdrazakov qui interprète
le rôle-titre de ce fameux opéra depuis
le début de sa carrière en 1998 ildar
abdrazakov à chanter dans le monde
entier de théâtre mariinsky de saint
pétersbourg à la scala de milan ou le
paiera de paris où il chante pour la
troisième fois après avoir interprété
donne carlos et boris godounov de
moussorgski
cette fois ils à leur titre de prince
igor il a pris le temps entre deux
répétitions de répondre à mes questions
[Musique]
en bottines à votre avis est ce qu'il y
a des points communs entre full votre
personnalité et celle de prince igor
votre personnage oui il y en a
quelques-unes déjà comme mon personnage
je suis quelqu'un qui lorsqu'il a un
objectif s'y tient vraiment je vais
droit au but et il me semble que c'est
une bonne chose
mon personnage est quelqu'un qui
lorsqu'il a une tâche fera tout pour en
venir à bout
et pour en ressortir comme un héros je
sais que dans les mises en scène d'opéra
il ya un metteur en scène et un
directeur musical
il arrive des désaccords des problèmes
entre les deux et vous interprète vous
arrivez à négocier entre les deux oui ça
existe parfois mais dans ce spectacle si
il n'y a pas de désaccord il arrive que
j'observe des désaccords entre un
metteur en scène et un chef d'orchestre
ce qui me concerne avant tout c'est la
partie musicale et ce qui est important
c'est de travailler ensemble on est en
permanence en contact avec eux le
metteur en scène vient met en place et
par et donc on travaille beaucoup plus
avec le directeur musical car la musique
est la partie la plus importante plus
important que la mise en scène je pense
j'espère que le metteur en scène ne m'en
voudra pas
[Musique]
à
oh
à votre avis qui parmi les grands
compositeurs russes a le plus écrit pour
des barytons mon sens qu'est moussorsgki
vous êtes talk about cependant si vous
prenez rien que boris godounov la
khovantchina nationale a beaucoup aussi
écrit pour les barytons tchaïkovski n'a
pas beaucoup composé mais le peu qu'il a
fait très beau comme mazeppa et le
magnifique opéra qui est eugène onéguine
j'aime vraiment beaucoup nos
compositeurs tous autant qu'ils sont
votre voix c'est en fait votre
instrument de travail
comment vous en prenez soin comme les
sportifs
nogué oui c'est comme les jambes d'un
coureur ou les mains d'un joueur
partners pour les sportifs ou pour nous
tout le corps est un instrument nous
connaissons notre corps par coeur
si on doit utiliser nos mains et nos
pieds que nous comprenons comment
raisonne notre organisme
- cash ont avant tout de nous libérer
sur scène et ne pas penser à aucun
problème personnel
et voilà jeté tous les problèmes du
quotidien ou pour ne plus en avoir en
tête pour qu'il ne reste plus que toi la
musique ton personnage des pensées et
des collègues sur scène pour que le
spectacle soit nous vivons pour jouer
pour chanter pour que ça reste gravé
dans notre vie comme si c'était la
première fois et les gens qui viennent
au théâtre le paie pour voir un vrai
spectacle aux spectateurs un spectacle
vivant
et
m
je
[Musique]
non
à
mais
là
[Musique]
quand et comment vous ressentez ses
liens culturels entre la russie et la
france
les liens culturels sont très puissants
1 un show que nos opéras sont joués à
paris et partout dans le monde
et quand je commence à travailler avec
un metteur en scène étrangers qui à bord
de la musique russe pour ce que mon il
absorbe directement les paroles quand tu
lui parles contexte duquel il ne saisit
pas tout les sens mais en général il
comprend le texte mais il ne ressent pas
exactement comme nous qu'il ne peut pas
le ressentir ou le comprendre riccio et
le fait de discuter du texte et de
l'expliquer avec d'autres mots là ils
finissent par capter le sens caché du
texte est en principe quand je travaille
dans d'autres langues comme dans l'opéra
de mozart don juan ou le mariage de
figaro je vois un millier a toujours un
sens caché du texte et un sens caché de
la musique et de peinture
[Musique]
merci d'avoir suivi avec nous cette
édition exceptionnelle
on se retrouve très vite pour de
prochaines découvertes de lisbonne à
vladivostok
[Musique]